foreign
let's get to know ketamine a bit better
by doing I don't want to say side by
side comparison but throwing it in the
mix with a lineup kind of the usual
suspect style
and the lineup consists of other
psychedelics and I should just take a
second to say that in my subjective
experience
particularly I don't advise this but at
the doses that sort of push you through
the Looking Glass which I think no one
really needs to do but I consider
ketamine much more of a psychedelic
compound at at higher doses then I do
something like MDMA if we take as
characteristic of psychedelic
experiences at higher doses ego
dissolution
Etc also I wanted to
hearken back to something you mentioned
which was solvent RNA being short
lasting short acting and I just want to
emphasize for anybody out there who's
maybe psychedelic naive or not
experienced that
short acting is is the most relative
term imaginable when applied to
psychedelic experience and I would say
short lasting and Earth time yes but
let's just say if it's in the case of NN
DMT or five Meo DMT only 15 to 20
minutes or 10 to 20 minutes like put
your hand on a hot stove and tell me
only 20 minutes
just not that you'd automatically have a
hot stove experience but it may not and
very frequently will not feel like
uh 20 minutes so to be aware of that but
if we look at
other psychedelics if we put ketamine in
that class for the time being or even
just put ketamine by itself and then
other psychedelics
there seem to be some
not all not totally overlapping but some
similar effects that release of
glutamate activating say mtor affecting
mtor bdnf so brain Drive neurotrophic
Factor what are some of the closest
comparables
that you've seen and how are they most
similar and how are they most different
I think you captured the the key point
of convergence which is these are
structurally these drugs are not at all
similar yeah mechanism of action these
drugs are not at all similar
and where they converge
which is you know
something you have to expect in the
brain which is just this enormously
complicated organ
that where they converge is how they
perturb the effects of
micro circuits and micro circuit being a
cluster of a small group of excitatory
and inhibitory cells that are you might
say the transistor if you will of the
transistor radio in other words the
lowest level that has the superordinate
properties that you're
that you can study in relation to
cognitive effects so
when you give a dose Academy you do two
things
mainly three things one is you do
activate inputs to the cortex from the
films
you're really disinhibiting them and
you're you're inhibiting the inhibitory
nerve cells the Gavin nerve cells so
you're locally reducing the degree of
inhibition and you're increasing a
little bit the excitatory input could
you just repeat the effect on the
thalamus and I'll just say this I don't
know if it's the best metaphor again but
is it fair to say the thalamus is a bit
like the traffic cop for sensory inputs
going to the brain it's like a relay
station that through which everything or
most things must pass before going to
the cortex for processing could you just
repeat the effect that ketamine has on
the thalvis so what I'm going to say
about ketamine and the hallucinogens and
the psychedelics if you will
are going to be complementary at each
stage of information processing ketamine
is relieving inhibition in the thalamus
in other words resulting secondarily in
excitation and hallucinogens
psychedelics are stimulating thalamic
neuronal act the output of the thalamic
neurons so you have sensory information
coming in and the ketamine is distorting
that message to the cortex and
psychedelics are creating a new message
and uh similarly in the cortex
ketamine is relieving inhibition and
thereby increasing activation and the
psychedelics are driving
autonomously excitation
essentially again creating a new message
and so that difference has been one of
the reasons that people have thought
that ketamine sensory experiences tend
to be more distortions of sensory
experience
in other words the walls are breathing
in and out my arm is now a foot longer
than it used to be you know things like
that whereas
oh look there's there's
um a shining glowing orb in the middle
of the room that wasn't there previous
you know from the psyched up right a
fully fledged hallucination in that way
they're not exactly the same in terms of
the micro circuit but they both have as
a common property this increase of
excitability increase in glutamate
output triggering the downstream
neurotrophic effects and triggering the
regrowth of the synapses that have been
lost in animal models and so we see
evidence hints of efficacy in the
Imperial College study and in the
studies done at Hopkins and and some of
the other trials and a little bit of a
stronger signal
in the
Compass data that's been released in the
press releases
but we do not yet have
data in the treatment resistant
depressed population and there are a lot
of reasons why we have different
populations being studied for the
different agents but to make a long
story short
even despite all the differences in the
clinical data at the basic science level
we do have this kind of common
effect on on micro circuits and regrowth
of synapses and and that's encouraging
as a potential foundation for the way
people think about the potential
therapeutic effects of of psychedelics